寝癖がひどい今じゃその社長ですね2018年今年も始冊を見てくださってありがとう
ございました
愛と勇気でこれがこのせ最後の動画になるんですけどもまぁ今年の投票ですねちょっと
待っとれっぽい話をさせていただきたいと思いますまあ
今年2018年は新しいことに挑戦できたん
1年だったと思います始め社長の畑っていうですね
まあグループチャンネルだけじゃないんですけど僕の周りにいる人たちで作っていく
ちゃんねるというのも作りましてこのチャンネルだ全く雰囲気とか出てくる人の人数を
違うんですけどまぁ新チャンネル始められたことは
すごい
今年一年の僕の画がれたところかなって思いますその山でもまあ今年で120万人超え
れって畑がうまくいっててまあ僕丁寧にいいなあと思ったんですけどめっちゃ忙しかっ
たですねがいつも忙しいってきすぎ急がせいい人っぽくなるんですけど
チャンネルいく増えたことによってシリーズらしくなっちゃったなって思って
自分の持てる体力をフルに使えってたのかなって思いますやめっちゃ楽しかったつでお
ぼいろんなことができ惰性環境もいろいろ変わったりして本当に素敵な一年だったん
ですけども
チャンネル3つあると音がか中時間の作り方が難しくてメインでやりたいことがあるん
だけどできないとか畑でも力尽きちゃってもう体力的にメインが取れなくなったりとか
結構あん
タンデマーそこは来年の課題かなと思ってますや力丸島田 not 入れたことだった
んですけどちょっとラないねはそういうちょっとなんだろうがむしゃらに頑張るだけ
じゃなくて行
ぐらい頭を使ってもといろんなことをしていければいいなと思っております
リングチェーンひどいのあの今年すごいことが1個ありまして
でかい炎上一回もしておりませんん
比較的おとなしく高温民に過ごせた1年だったかなって思います
いうわけでまあ今年もたくさん動画とったんで
とりあえずはダイジェストどうぞよ
ん
ああああああ
が本当に甘いよこれ
ああああああああ
わー
ああああああああああああ
par
びっくりベクレああ
さあ集めだろうーっ
また方
ねそうなんですよねぇ
じゃねえええ
えっこんな[ __ ]だせえけどなね
ローンは借りパクしますああ
骨折りましたん
正しい
[音楽]
goo
バー
ああああああ
トッターけどギルのご覧いけるいけるぞって和美ハザード4
ダガーだけは言うな入ってる
いくを提出しまーすうーん米屋い直エンジンなど俺みたいな
たぁー
search 国会バンッ japan 同署何もできない
えっどんな音がなった求めます
can ちぇんじ所沢の
ん
彼女ですみたいですん
みたいです何も見えません大先輩いい第五
やっぱりやりましたね
[音楽]
それで亡くしました
ああああああ
続きある履かないなぁと黒言ってますはい
ディスコじゃねーかん
うぉっ
こんばんわん
8時になりました5
くだせいやーっ
数メートルん
じゃんゲインって言ってくれよ
まだ全然ローゼ
いた人だけ
[音楽]
風びっくりさあーうっ
人ってパニくると思うんですよ噂を迎えたところ
[音楽]
会場の次行きましょうん
まずいいうーん b
ああああああ
入れる多分期待する割安ウイ
[音楽]
me
幸せ切る理由のでいきたいに手を触れたん
近衛グランディスカラー
pandan
同じ空っつってるかまぁちょっとあってかといけません
いけますよお金を知らせ
[音楽]
んどうぞこれは何ですかああ
[拍手]
ああああああ
yeah
hp バーサーカーイダああああ
パワーまい棒をみなさんに無料で配ら桜と思いますどうぞ
うわぁスプーンをそれはた四球はポケモンを捕まえることですねーかな
私服だよっしゃーっ
てくる can
[音楽]
rar
ちょっ完全にする
牡丹部に ban を張って般若
キャンペーン
んうわぁああああううぅうぅん
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
[音楽]
太田よっ
このいやーあんな新しい積んでと作りますチーツーこれダメます月ば旅スケ
苗字だってねぇ
を治療ネオ
amaran
ああああああ
[音楽]
もうどんな水ですよだってカフェはーい
いささかね30
めっちゃなぁレザー
やったねー
めっちゃ簡単じゃないですか
ここへし得ない
ああああああ
除い yeah
wh
たてから追われやばいまあわかるよね動かすですねうんハロウィーン
カラー oha
ああああああ
100万円場があったら面白いと思って170万円にしましたオーバーカーやー
[音楽]
うわぁ全部消してるこいつらや離れで終われ
ああ
ru n 8
car
ああああああああああああ
畑口んだ包丁が握られていたあー
はあああああ
[音楽]
まあなんやかんや色々やっていましたが
あの
僕が今年
一番頑張ったのは
動画ではありません
[音楽]
パズドラだよ
me
あっはぁ